♪ ♪
RONNA McDANIEL A GOOD EVENING
AND WELCOME INTO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
JUST ABOUT THREE YEARS AND
DONALD TRUMP DONALD TRUMP WAS
INAUGURATED, THE LEFT HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO END THE IN
ADMINISTRATION BY NONDEMOCRATIC
MEANS.
AT TONIGHT THAT THEY'RE CLOSER
THAN EVER TO REACHING THE GOAL.
YET, AND ANOTHER REMINDER THAT
HUMAN NATURE IS MORE COMPLEX
THAN THE HUMAN GENOME, THEY
DON'T APPEAR VERY HAPPY ABOUT
IT.
IN FACT, CLOSER THE IMPEACHMENT
GETS, THE MORE DESPONDENT THEY
SEEM.
AS THE BUDDHA HIMSELF ONCE
NOTED, MAN LUNGS TO
DRINK THROUGH A LOTUS BLOSSOM TO
DISCOVER THE NECTAR IS MOST
BITTER OF ALL.
THEY HAD HIGH HOPES FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEY WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT.
YOU COULD BE MILDLY CRITICAL
FROM TIME TO TIME, BUT MORE IN
THE MOST LOVING WAY AS A PARENT
CORRECTS A CHILD.
OPPORTUNITY FOR SELF
IMPROVEMENTS.
UNDERNEATH IT ALL, THEY WERE
ROOTING FOR DONALD TRUMP, THEY
WANT, WE STRIP IT ALL THE WAY
THEY ARE PATRIOTS TOO.
THEY WANT WHAT IS BEST FOR THE
COUNTRY.
IF PASTOR GOOD INTENTIONS ROLLED
DONALD TRUMP'S FAITHFUL PHONE
CALL TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UKRAINE THAT CHANGED EVERYTHING.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO OVERTURN A
DEMOCRACY IN ORDER TO SAVE A
DEMOCRACY.
IN FACT IT'S ENOUGH TO MAKE A
HARDENED POLITICAL FIGURE LIKE
NANCY PELOSI BE UPSET.
>> THIS IS A VERY SAD TIME FOR
OUR COUNTRY.
I SAY THIS VERY FEARFULLY AND
CAREFULLY.
THIS IS A VERY SAD TIME FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
IT IS VERY SAD TO, WE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL.
I PRAY FOR THE PRESIDENT ALL THE
TIME.
THIS IS A VERY SAD TIME FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
THERE IS NO JOY IN THIS.
IT IS SAD AND WE MUST BE SOMBER
AND WE MUST BE PRAYERFUL AND WE
MUST PROCEED AS FURTHER.
>> Tucker: IT'S JUST SAD,
THERE'S NO JOY IN THIS.
WE ARE SOMBER.
PRAYERFUL.
THAT'S THE OFFICIAL POSITION OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND THEY
ROLLED IT OUT AND THEY TESTED IT
THIS WEEKEND TALKING FOR ONE OF
THE SUNDAY SHOWS AND TELLINGLY,
THAT A SINGLE NEWS ANCHOR
CHALLENGED THEM ON ITS GREATEST
STRANGELY, THOUGH, NO ONE SEEMS
TO INFORM CONGRESSWOMAN ONE OF
THE PARTIES MOST VISIBLE LEVERS,
SHE STILL SELLING T-SHIRTS
EMBLAZONED WITH HER MOST FAMOUS
QUOTE IMPEACH THE MOTHER F'ER."
INSTEAD, A WEEKEND OF
CONTEMPLATIVE PRAYER.
SHE WILL GET ON IT AT SOME
POINT.
GOD WILL KNOW WHAT SHE SAYS WHEN
SHE DOES.
SAY WHAT HE WILL ABOUT HER OTHER
FRIENDS OF THE SQUAD, THERE'S A
LOT MORE, THERE'S A LOT MORE
HONEST THAN WINDBAGS LIKE
NANCY PELOSI.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN BOTHERED TO
WEEP AND PRAY.
WE'VE BEEN PRAY?
THEY ARE THRILLED!
THEIR LITTLE CLOSER TO 92
SEIZING POWER.
IT'S THEIR PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
GOOD.
THEY COULD CARE LESS ABOUT THE
SYSTEM THEY WOULD LIKE TO TEAR
THE SYSTEM DOWN.
IF THAT'S THE POINT.
MAINSTREAM DEMOCRATS MEANWHILE,
THOUGH, EVER WORRIED ABOUT WHAT
NORMAL PEOPLE MIGHT THINK ARE
STILL TRENDING OUT INCREASINGLY
POSSIBLE LIES.
WE SEE THE LATEST TONIGHT THAT'S
MAYBE THE BEST.
THEY'RE TELLING YOU THAT THE
UKRAINE SAGA IS ACTUALLY ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY CONCERNS.
WATCH.
SPEAK OUT THAT HIS CLASSIC ABUSE
OF POWER WHICH UNDERMINES THE
NATIONAL SECURITY.
IF THIS IS AS SERIOUS AS IT
GETS.
>> PRESIDENT HAS PUT AT RISK OR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> OUR PRESIDENT SACRIFICE TO
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS MATTER
OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> PRESIDENT UNITED STATES IS
WILLING TO COMPROMISE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> THE TIPPING POINT IS CLEAR,
IT WAS NATIONAL SECURITY FULL
STOP.
>> Tucker: NATIONAL SECURITY!
A CAUSEY OR CORTEZ WHO COULD NOT
FIND UKRAINE ON THE BIG TYPE
MATH.
HOW DID THE PRESIDENT
JEOPARDIZED THE SECURITY, BY
DELAYING, THEY SAY, MILITARY AID
TO UKRAINE.
THAT JEOPARDIZES OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
YEAH.
IF ANYTHING JEOPARDIZES OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY, IT'S SENDING
MINDLESSLY SENDING MILITARY AID
TO UKRAINE IN ORDER TO
ANTAGONIZE RUSSIA.
WHAT DO WE GET OUT OF THAT?
COULD COME UP WITH THE ANSWER?
OH, THERE'S NO ANSWER.
WE DON'T GET ANYTHING OUT OF
THIS AT ALL.
OF COURSE, NO ONE IN THE PRESENT
PAUSES FOR 32ND TO QUESTION THE
POOR STORY AT THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
IF WERE SENDING CLOSE TO HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS TO UKRAINE
BECAUSE WHY?
BECAUSE AN COUPLE OF PEOPLE
THINK WE SHOULD?
PLEASE.
ANOTHER THING THAT PUTS OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AT RISK FOR
REAL IS WHEN YOU MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
ANY PRESIDENT TO HAVE PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIS
COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER COUNTRIES
BAITED WITH OTHER FOREIGN
LEADERS
REMEMBER THE CLOSEST WORLD EVER
CAME TO WHERE WAS 1952 WITH THE
MISSILE CRISIS.
HOW DID THAT AND?
HOW DID IT DE-ESCALATE YOU.
IT ENDED WHEN OUR PRESIDENT
REACHED A DEAL WITH THE SOVIET
PRESIDENT WHEN THEY SECRETLY,
THEY MAKE CONCESSIONS TO ONE
ANOTHER SECRETLY.
I COULD NOT HAVE DONE IT IN ANY
OTHER WAY.
IF THEY WERE SELF-RIGHTEOUS
AROUND IN 96    96 E2, THE WORLD
AROUND IN 96    96 E2, THE WORLW
AROUND IN 96    96 E2, THE WORLU
AROUND IN 96    96 E2, THE WORLD
HAVE BLOWN UP.
THAT THAT'S NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT.
IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
IT'S THIS PRESIDENT OR ANY
PRESIDENT CAN'T PERCEIVE WITH
THE EXPECTATION OF THAT AT HIS
OWN COST, HIS CORE ABOUT THE JOB
WILL REMAIN PRIVATE.
HONESTLY, THEY CARE ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY BECAUSE THE
MONK'S
YEAH, THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THIS IS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT IS THE MOST ANNOYING.
IT'S ABOUT POWER.
IT'S ABOUT A POWER GRAB.
IT SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT AOC
AND THE REST OF THOSE HYPER
AGGRESSIVE, AT LEAST THEY'RE
HONEST ABOUT THAT.
THERE'S SOMETHING SORT OF NICE.
ABOUT SOMEONE WHO IS HONEST
ABOUT HIS AIMS EVEN IF THE AIMS
ARE DISGUSTING AND CONTEMPTIBLE
AND SCARY WHICH IS POWER
GRABBING.
AT LEAST YOU DON'T HAVE TO WADE
THROUGH A BUNCH OF SELF
RIGHTEOUS AIR TO GET THERE.
BOTTOM LINE, DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WANTS TO PRETEND THE 2016
ELECTIONS NEVER HAPPENED AND
MAKE SURE IT CAN NEVER HAPPEN
AGAIN.
AS WASHINGTON EXPRESSES THE FAKE
CONCERNS ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY, YOU CAN'T PRETEND TO
BE WORRIED, NO ONE THINKS
HUNDRED BIDEN DESERVES THAT GIG
IN UKRAINE.
NO ONE SEEMS A SENSE THAT HE GOT
IT ANYWAY.
LAST WEEK FOR EXAMPLE, JOE BIDEN
TOLD PETER DOOCY THIS IS ABOVE
BECAUSE HE NEVER TALKED WITH US
ON WHAT HE DID ABROAD.
WATCH.
>> I NEVER SPOKE TO MY SON ABOUT
THE OVERSEA --
HERE'S WHAT I KNOW.
I KNOW THAT TRUMP DESERVES TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
HE IS VIOLATING A BRIEF BASIC
NORM OF THE PRESIDENTS.
IF YOU SHOULD BE ASKING HIM THE
QUESTIONS.
WHY IS HE ON THE FOAM WITH A
FOREIGN LEADER?
>> YOU SHOULD BE ASKING HIM
ABOUT WHAT HE'S DOING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO SEE.
BUT THE QUESTION IS THE FACTUAL
MATTER BECAUSE THIS IS A NEWS
CHANNEL, WE WILL ANSWER THE
QUESTION, THE MOST BASIC ONE.
IS BIDEN'S CLAIM TRUE?
PHOTOGRAPH OBTAINED EXCLUSIVELY
BY THE SHOW, NOT TO BREAK, BUT
WE DID SUGGEST THE CLAIM BY DON
MIKE MIGHT NOT BE INTERPRETED
BIDEN ON A 2014 GOLFING TRIP
WITH HIS SON AS WELL AS HIS SON